every now and then I think about why I
like comics so much pictures in sequence
telling a story what's not to love
everyone loves film you don't have to
justify why do you like film that a
comic book at its minimum is a film that
you can read at your own speed I'm Kevin
Maroney I've been slowly accumulating
comics of over the last 40 years I have
about twenty to thirty thousand of them
only 18 and 36 cents and that's before
before my desk at a discount that's not
my weekly when I think about how much
money I spent on the comics collection
it scares me it's certainly tens of
thousands of dollars over the year now
strike that it's hundreds of thousands
of dollars over the years so where are
the dooms again actually next one day my
wife also grew up reading comics she was
reading the x-men before I had heard of
them and one of the ways in which i
wooed her was I brought her comic books
I said oh you'll really like this and
gave her Swamp Thing and watchmen we
merged our comics collections which is
as any married couple will tell you as a
traumatic experience how the commitment
there we just drown in comics happily
when I was very young like a lot of very
young foolish comics buyer's I thought
that I was buying treasure comics are
not a good investment everyone knows the
stories of someone discovering that they
have a spider-man hidden in inside the
wall of their house and selling it for
more than the house is worth most comic
books especially most comic books
published during my lifetime are worth
literally nothing 1989 1990 for there
was just an investor frenzy like you
would not believe comics that had been
selling a hundred thousand copies a
month we're selling a million within six
months the market had completely
collapsed eighty percent of the comic
shops in America were closed within a
year Marvel went into bankruptcy a few
years after that now of course they're a
big part of disney so things can bounce
back one could probably make a nice
little superhero narrative out of the
the comics industry being pummeled down
by the the evil speculator and then
gathering its strength around it and
bursting forward but that would be kind
of you know comic booky